Велика подорож маленького будиночка - так званого "тайні хауз".
Його розмістять у Ганновері на півночі Німеччини. На задньому дворі житлового будинку,
що належить комунальному житлово-будівельному товариству.
Транспортні витрати - 10 тисяч євро. Цей "тайні хауз" виготовили в Естонії.
Чотири з них розмістили тут. Ціна будиночка - 75 тисяч євро.
В одному з них живе банкір Даніель Вайс.
Я зрозумів, що насправді почуваюся комфортніше в таких маленьких приміщеннях
і збагнув, що тут я, так би мовити, більш міська людина, і проблема,
що в місті дотепер не було жодних житлових проєктів.
Пральна міні-машина. З 30 квадратних метрів використано кожен сантиметр.
Вишуканий мінімалізм. Ажіотаж на такі квартири величезний:
брали участь 150 претендентів. Даніелю навіть довелося провести презентацію у Power Point,
перш ніж його обрали серед інших претендентів. Тепер він жартує.
Гадаю, коти відіграли вирішальну роль.
Загалом по всій Німеччині гостро бракує житла.
Спершу були високі ціни на нерухомість, а потім знову зростання відсоткових ставок.
Навіть людям з великими доходами важко дозволити собі будинок за нинішньої ситуації.
Ті, хто більш-менш заробляє, раніше могли дозволити собі такі односімейні будинки,
але нині вони в дефіциті. І дорогі! За останні 10 років ціна зросла вдвічі.
До 400 тисяч євро і більше.
Столяр Ульф Трюбель та його партнерка побачили у цьому ринкову нішу.
Вони виготовляють маленькі будиночки. Коли "тайні хауз" готовий, його доставляють
клієнтам автобаном. Такі будиночки з’явилися вже по всій Німеччині.
Ульф та Діана також живуть в одному з таких поселень. Але крихітні будиночки схвалені
владою переважно лише в кемпінгових поселеннях.
Причина - багато мерій не бажають визнавати цей новий тип житла будинками
та забороняють їх у своїх селах. Це дратує власників.
Такий маленький будинок - це завжди можливо. На колесах чи не на колесах.
Незалежно від того, ми також будуємо його з колесами чи без них.
Чому я маю впиратися в те, що формат цього села - червоні дахи, зелені дахи
чи щось таке? Це повна нісенітниця.
Зовсім поруч крихітний будинок його партнерки. Вона була першою клієнткою
і замовляла у нього. Сьогодні вони - і пара, і сусіди. У кожного свій маленький будиночок.
Гадаю, це добре, що ви можете просто бути разом, якщо захочете.
Але можна також просто зачинити двері і сказати: "Ок, сьогодні один вечір
я побуду в себе вдома".
Ситуація з дефіцитом житла у Німеччині ще більше загострилася торік,
коли у ФРН прибуло понад мільйон біженців з України. Це створило додаткові замовлення
для виробників таких будиночків, як, приміром, для цієї компанії у Східній Німеччині.
Її керівник Маріо Дроґіс вже звів шість таких будинків,
чотири з них призначені виключно для сімей біженців.
Цей іде в Нойштадт-Гольштейн. Тут є чотири інших, їх також незабаром відправлять.
Там розмістять українських біженців. А коли вони поїдуть додому, я думаю, що ці будиночки
потрібно використовувати для відпочивальників.
Тут, на півночі Німеччини, вони вже є: маленькі будиночки для українських біженців.
Ними опікується голова місцевої соціальної установи.
Цей пристрій-перекладач допомагає йому спілкуватися з ними.
Я записала свого сина до школи, йому там дуже, дуже подобається.
Ситуація дуже напружена. На ринку житла майже не залишилося квартир.
З огляду на це ми придбали ці будиночки. З іншого боку, ми не можемо купити
нове житло для кожного біженця, який приїде.
Цій жінці пощастило, вчотирьох її родина живе в цьому новому крихітному будиночку.
Є спальня для сина та невістки і ще одна для батьків. Мерія заплатила за цей будинок 90 тисяч євро.
Українці Яні довелося покинути своє невеличке господарство в Україні.
Разом з нею приїхав її син та чоловік. Родина жила в селі під Маріуполем.
Нині ця територія окупована Росією.
Наше життя було щасливим. Ми навіть не уявляли, які ми щасливі й багаті люди
до 24 лютого 2022 року, коли прийшла в наш дім війна.
Першими ми побачили колони російської техніки, військових з автоматами.
Було дуже страшно. Ми з дітьми сиділи у підвалі.
З маленькими сусідськими дітьми.
Її новий будинок маленький, але красивий. Яна збирається пожити тут певний час,
але після війни хоче обов'язково повернутися в Україну.